why doesn't bruce springsteen do a cheap
commercial about the
woody allen rape america's strength is
in the middle
dylan no matter what happened and woody
no matter what happened
america's strengths in the middle we
need to you both need to come together
america's strength is down the center
i'm gonna go crash my car i'm a big
truck
how'd i love that he got a dewey yeah
they redacted like 24 pages of that
they're trying to
make it public what he's doing yeah but
it's still like under investigation so i
imagine there's some very embarrassing
stuff in there
well he said some racist [ __ ] i'm sure i
know he's all like you know
mr progressive but you know when when he
got pulled over where do you get pulled
over we don't know but
oh i don't know if we know if they
pulled him over on a garden state
parkway he said a few things
don't you know who i am i'm the boss
i'm a white man how great would that be
if bruce springsteen just
the transcript he's screaming i'm a
white man born in the usa
i'm a what i mean
it's amazing jeep went through with that
commercial despite in november him
having this they don't care people like
people it's better
people enjoy it people want their
celebrities to get drunk
and get crash cars they don't care if
you're buying a
grand cherokee if you're buying
imagine buying a jeep grand cherokee
if you're buying a jeep grand cherokee
as brilliantly nick mullen said
it's for jarhead like retards who come
back from the war with flashbacks
if you're buying a jeep grand cherokee
you don't care that bruce springsteen's
a drunk
or that woody allen raped his kid
doesn't matter to you what's a product
it would go through with woody allen
even though he's
dylan's coming out with his dock what's
a product that would go go through
woody allen no matter like they wouldn't
care i'm trying to think
a product that would just people
wouldn't they wouldn't be affected by it
because jeep doesn't care about drunk
bruce springsteen
what product would get behind pedo woody
allen like four loko maybe
no too ethnic you'd have to have
something kind of classy
like yoplait like yo play yogurt
yeah you know just an erotic woody allen
being like i don't have any i don't even
eat but
i like cow play they go they're in the
boardroom they're like
listen our yogurt is for like french
pedophiles
who cares in the same way that jeep was
like
our cars are for people that are drunk
while
buying the car it's for people that are
trying to drink their
traumas to the back of their [ __ ]
head
i think the ceo jeep gives a [ __ ]
uh a bob
bad news bruce just got popped on the
garden state parkway they got him on the
they popped him on the turnpike and he's
screaming sandy n word
he goes good release that we'll use that
as a commercial
they originally wanted bruce drunk
screaming the n-word is the jeep
commercial
but they had to do that other horseshit
he goes that's good i want to see
bloated bruce springsteen get thrown in
the back of a cruiser
and then the jeeps just sitting there
and they go nobody stops the boss
from the reports that emerged the
officer allegedly observed springsteen
consuming what appeared to be alcohol in
the park and then starting up his
motorcycle
oh he was on a motorcycle that's great
next time drive a jeep
the lawyer says it might look like a
shot of tequila but who knows what it
was it might have been a shot of
gatorade
i swear to god that's like a direct
quote that's a real jersey lawyer
he's being represented by some real
jersey lawyer
the same guy representing woody allen
hey it might look like a kid saying that
uh they got [ __ ] up in the attic but
we it might be a kid playing a prank
might also be a kid playing games you
know how kids do it's a shot of gatorade
i mean would it what a country all of
our heroes are collapsing in front of us
folks they're collapsing
there's nothing left to do except
embrace the mediocrity and the horror
that will come with people that don't
make
moral that aren't bad like they don't
rape and
maim and murder and kill
you know just let mr beast curate the
country
yes just let mr beast feed us
let mr beast decide what the art's gonna
be
just let nerds do it i'm not saying he's
a nerd but he probably is probably just
let autists do
everything now just let people that
can't say hello to you
run the world they can't shake a hand or
look in anyone's eye
they can't rape anyone they can't even
say hello